this is a production of Cornell
University thank you as a pleasure to be
here I mean a little bit more height and
pared the dawn so I hope everybody can
see me from at least the nose above over
this this monitor it's good to see all
these familiar faces and some new ones
feel like I'm back in plantations we
could have had this over the Nevin
Welcome Center and the Lord Geneva well
yes I'm gonna be talking a little bit
about bio cultural conservation and I'm
gonna go through slowly getting to that
point but then talk about why it's
important that the tenant gardens play a
role both in environmental biological
conservation as well as cultural and
linguistic to make sure I could find the
right button here but first of all just
a little bit about plantations for those
of you who don't get out much or for
those who are newer than I it might be
just useful to just have a a little
brief overview as to who we are and what
we do but our mission if you just want
to boil it down to three words it's
probably not much different from any
other public garden in the world we
involved in cultivation of plants of
course and their display conservation
which includes these days also very
heavy focus on sustainability and
sustainable practices and education both
formal and informal because of the way
we do these things with a high level of
professionalism curatorial
professionalism we do consider ourselves
as do zoos and aquaria as living museums
we curate our collections with the
highest degree of professional accuracy
we to know everything about every plant
that comes in where it came from how
it's doing with us health is as
provenance all these kinds of things and
this makes the collections that we have
much more useful and easier to be
integrated into various scientific and
academic activities so as such were
integral to cows as well as to Cornell
more broadly and is that more broadly
part that I think may become a little
bit more apparent as we go through this
in terms of other kinds of academic
and again for those who don't get out
much
it's plantations as a fairly complex
entity with the botanic gardens around
the Welcome Center they are breed them
across the way here as well as 34
natural areas that so the total land
area is somewhere around 3,500 was more
acres that's worth about Hector's acres
so we are a place that provides solace
provides places for recreation informal
and formal education as I was saying
before places in which faculty can bring
their students our students can bring
themselves down there and learn and
study and reflect so our collections are
based on any number of different themes
some may be more Geographic or
ecological and some more horticultural
or taxonomic such as the rhododendron
garden the York Robeson York state herb
garden pam shade is the gardener
extraordinaire for this plot it's one of
the best but reputed to be one of the
best or gardens in the country and it's
absolutely a fantastic resource for
anybody who's interested in the ways in
which herbs have been used and for
culinary purposes medicinal purposes and
art and literature and the like and
through history and you know Don was
sort of alluding to the weather right
now and how am i adapting but I'm doing
fine actually I'm going to Hawaii on
Wednesday
for a few days this business store it's
all business but even this time of year
there's plenty to do outside in terms of
horticulture and the winter interest as
a horticulturist or landscape
architect's say of gardens in the
weren't that could be quite stunning and
striking with gives you more of an
opportunity to look at parts of the
plant other than the leaves and the
flowers you can look at the bark and the
color and buds and fruits that are still
hanging on there so the mules student
family winter garden is a fantastic
resource of course is the hundred acre
Arboretum all the natural errors that
are around us the cascade el informe
Creek Gorge trails which are all part of
our under our purview and then getting
into the some of the sustainability
things I haven't talked about the Devon
Welcome Center but you know that dog
knows more about this and I do LEED
certified the bias well garden helping
manage some of the runoff that comes
from the surrounding air in the parking
lots etc and sort of filtering it by Oh
filtering it before it gets into the
water gets into B V Lake the faculty and
student research is something that I
really want to put a great deal of
emphasis on in the next few years not
just to our sort of kinship in in the
Plant Sciences and horticulture and
environmental sciences but also in the
humanities as well and bringing more of
a more artists down there and musicians
and and the like and really bulk up our
education programs so that we appeal to
a broad cadre of students be they people
who are looking for a formal education
or those who've just come in for a more
informal experience so for me and for
many of us here plants are inspirational
they inspire us in terms of our research
or in terms of the way we manage our
gardens at home or at work and they've
inspired some people to serve rather
perplexing ways of displaying plants in
some places such as in Versailles but
also they inspire in terms of other
kinds of things we have charismatic mega
fauna such as the panda bear and
elephants this kind of thing we do have
charismatic megafauna as well for
Christ's sake so we need to try and get
people involved and excited about the
world of plants through any kinds of
hook and plants and nature natural
systems
have inspired the arts and many any
number of ways and this is one of my
favorite recent novels Barbara
Kingsolver is Prodigal summer which has
a great exposition of how nature works
but also how people interact with nature
and some of the conflicts that are there
and some of the ways in which those two
different types of systems mesh and of
course it shows up in any you know in
art through the painting through the
ages this is child Haslam's painting of
celia faxes garden and what's now Shoals
Marine Lab her Appledore Island
mrs. Syria facts are in her garden so
we're inspired by the art that the art
was inspired by the gardens would all
come sort of full circle I can come full
circle in other ways too such as putting
art at the garden such as Chihuly's
Glass Works this was a recent I'm not
that recent I guess almost 10 years old
installation it fits but Dale Chihuly
has been traipsing around the world
putting in his glass work and various
places and I think this is great to a
point if people come just for the art
and forget to look at anything else
around it I'm not sure that much has
been achieved other than the cash
register ringing and then of course here
we have these sculptures which were part
of a student project back in the 60s so
these are now sculptures in the
Arboretum but actually the Arboretum
came later probably about 20 years later
these were put in in the early 60s and
the Arboretum wasn't officially
established until 1982 so this whole
thing sort of you might say sort of this
forest grew up around these things and
then Jack Elliott who's over in human
ecology his sculpture well actually
sawed a sculpture it is a maple root
structure that was in front of the
Johnson Museum for a while last summer
and then we had to transport it down to
us so the ways in which we can engage
people in art that has a botanical or
environmental focus and then get them
hooked and then get more talking about
plants of what they mean to them and
their daily lives and in today's society
and one of the unfortunate aspects of
today's society is that many of the
plants and natural resources or systems
that we study are increasingly
threatened by one thing or another one
thing being land-use changes in
deforestation in the base of species
climate change
so I hear for instance that this has an
impact not just climate changes impact
not only on natural systems but on
gardening and how we garden so here's
the hardiness zone map from 1919 you can
see here we are firmly ensconced in zone
5
and here zone 3 up here the dark area
now here in the 2006 version we're
almost out of zone 5 and look what
happened to zone 3 is almost
non-existent in the conterminous United
States so this has a great impact on
gardening as well as our ability to
manage our collections and Botanic
Gardens and we need to be thinking ahead
as to how we're going to manage our
collections and the light of these
changes now one great thing about being
a living museum and keeping great
records on everything that we do is we
can look at phenological data that we
have in our archives and in our
notebooks and look to see how
phenological events have changed over
the course of time and we were doing
this in Chicago and also in Hawaii the
Royal Botanic Garden q has been doing a
lot of work on this and we have
colleagues that in Boston - Richard
Primack who's been publishing quite
extensively on this phenomenon as well
but if you look at the flowering dates
of narcissus at Kew back in the 1950s -
the average flowering date was the 9th
of March and now it's late January so
it's almost six weeks shift in the
flowering phenology just of that one
species they did this for about two
dozen different spring flowering
ephemeral and perennials - and see this
very similar shift and it's anywhere
from about four weeks to eight to ten
weeks so significant and I just got an
email from a friend in in Germany last
week saying spring is here already so
it's amazing so these things these
various environmental issues have a pose
a great threat to the plant life of the
world and Chris Thomas could publish a
paper about ten years ago looking at how
many species in the world are quote
unquote committed to extinction if the
current trends continue and for
separated
operating out plans from everything else
he indicated that depending on where you
are in the Amazon for instance and
what's already had been occurring in
certain places within the Amazon
anywhere from 50 to 80 percent of the
flora there's at risk of extinction in
the next 50 years or so so in Europe is
not quite so bad not because it's a more
resilient system but because so much is
already we've even wiped out there's
only very little left to be wiped out so
nor Myers and others since him have
developed what we call biodiversity
hotspots which are just regions of the
world for the flora and fauna is a
particular risk of extinction due to
simple's factors that I've already
mentioned and as you know and as you can
see from here these tend to be in the
tropics and subtropics and in the
Mediterranean region and you know
sometimes you say out of crisis comes
opportunity and this is an opportunity
for us I suppose as a profession and in
a horticulture and the Botanic Garden
community to take a leadership role and
better understanding and communicating
about some of these issues that are
happening and the effects that they will
have on the natural world british
ecologist william sutherland was looking
at all of this and looking at
endangerment of birds and mammals using
the IUCN that's the International Union
for the Conservation of Nature using
their red listing criteria and
determined that of the almost 10,000
species of bird in the world twelve
percent of them are at risk of
extinction in the next few decades of
the forty five hundred or so species of
mammals 24 percent then he said to
himself well that's for fun just try and
use these IUCN criteria for endangerment
and see how they might apply to
something else like endangered languages
and it doesn't work very well but he
tried to shoehorn some of these things
into those criteria and came up with a
number of 25% of the world's languages
are endangered so bits of our humanity
are as threatened as other aspects of
the
by out of the world however that's
actually a quite a low estimate because
they're better ways of estimating the
percentages of languages that are
endangered and UNESCO uses a fairly
rigorous set of criteria and they've
estimated that about 50% of the 7,000
existing languages are endangered and
long-term trends losing about a language
about every two weeks so about this time
last year there was the last living
speaker of a language in Scotland is
called a fisher folk language that
person died so that language is gone and
there was something in the press maybe
several weeks ago about the last speaker
of a Native American language in the
southwest so we're seeing this happening
more and more more more frequently so
people who study endangered languages
have tried to mimic some of these Hut's
this hotspot theme and looking in
language extinction hotspots and again
as you might expect the greatest
vulnerability is in the tropics and
subtropics where natural systems are
being rapidly degraded by deforestation
and resource extraction and native
peoples indigenous peoples being
displaced of course there are the other
pockets up in north western North
America and northeastern Russia and
China as well for their small isolated
indigenous groups so for looking at the
relationship so what we're seeing here
is the explicit relationship
cause-and-effect relationship between
the loss of biological diversity around
the world and the loss of linguistic and
cultural diversity that go hand-in-hand
as as one erodes away is taking the
others down with it and so this
examination of the relationship between
biological conservation and cultural or
linguistic conservation be called bio
cultural conservation and this is an
area I think gardens can be become more
deeply engaged in as we lose a culture
or language was the information that
they have they what we call the
indigenous ecological knowledge or
traditional ecological knowledge about
the natural world around them I went to
a lecture last year from by a woman
whose I don't know what you call her
sort of it may be an ethnomusicologist
but she was looking at Aboriginal dad
dances and various groups through
northern Australia and she's shown these
videos of these people dancing and then
she was sort of breaking it down parsing
it down showing how each motion had
something to do with the lifecycle of a
species of bird when it fledged when to
bread how many offspring it had so this
whole ritual around it so once that
language is gone and all that knowledge
we may call it indigenous or traditional
ecological knowledge but it's damn good
ecological knowledge all that does
disappears so we're all the poorer for
it as as humanity so if you're born ho
ye or a Native Hawaiian and any one of
these particular plants were to
disappear then the Native Hawaiian
culture which is now going through a
Renaissance we lose a significant
portion of its identity so the taro
which is a important staple crop the koa
or Ocasio Cove which is used for
building canoes and other utilitarian
vessels though here the Metro sinteres
which is used in lei making and other
kinds of ornamental purposes these are
some people might refer to these as sort
of cultural keystone species as as
opposed to ecological keystone species
but they're central to the culture once
they're gone they're gone and the taro
as some of you might know is a sacred
plant throughout many of the Pacific
island cultures they believe that that's
their ancestry and I won't get into the
mythology of that at the moment but in
vanilla lava for instance the residents
there say we don't we do not cultivate
taro to live but live to cultivate taro
because it's keeping alive their
ancestral heritage and if you follow the
news about GMO and all that kind of
thing there's been quite a bit of hue
and cry about this particularly in the
Pacific Islands I mean it worked ok with
the papaya and in fact there was a
Cornell breeder who came up with a ring
spot resistant papaya and that's now
being widely grown in Hawaii but that's
one of the exceptions there also
diseases of taro that have been going
you know through the Pacific from time
to time and wiped out much of the taro
cultivation and some more and so they
resorted reluctantly to using GMO taro
well the Hawaiians had no way the new
eleven said no way because you don't do
GM
your ancestor I mean it's just heretical
so there's been a lot of place instances
in which sort of quote-unquote Western
science or Western approach just the
things that conflicted or intersection
with some of the other traditional ones
but it's an opportunity for learning
more about how other cultures see the
world around them and and appreciate
that more or heavily so the respect to
sea-level rise again in the Pacific the
Republic of Kiribati which is about 32
flat coral atolls no more than 2 meters
high and for these a trivial thing so
somebody says what was the only country
in the world which spans which but is
present in all four hemispheres so
bikini bus because the International
Dateline comes right down here and the
equator goes right through here so it's
at all four hemispheres anyway so sea
level rise just a few centimeters of sea
level rise is gonna cause huge issues as
it is now here's the capital town it's
under water your people who have never
seen water above their knees on these
atolls is now already up to their ankles
or above and so now what they're doing
is trying to find a home they're gonna
be one of the first in full entire
nations that is sort of an environmental
refugee status Fiji at the time I put
this together negotiating to buy another
negotiating can we just please live
there five thousand acres in Fiji Fiji
is saying no at the moment another
seeing of either Australia or New
Zealand will take some of them these
people is about a hundred thousand
people now if you go a little further
afield up to the northwest North America
this is Alaska and the Northwest
Territories they're about two dozen
different languages and cultures here of
First Nations people or whatever the
appropriate term is these days any one
of which is dwindling so if you look at
this area up here with a new pot or in
the far northern part as a sea level as
icy water temperature rises they're
finding the whales and other mammals and
animals that they hunt are moving
the north and so they're out there
hunting in these sort of rudimentary
canoes and they can't get out this far
or they may be able to get out as far
but there's no where they're gonna get
back in time and so their ability to
hunt for the resources that they need is
being increasingly diminished there's a
nice write-up about this in a book
recently
valina that's the name of the town in
which they they live so these
environmental changes are changing the
natural world is having a direct
consequence in the cultural world and
here as part of their landscape that's
just literally melting and going away
and going into the ocean so people who
study this botanist and ethno botanist
s-- anthropologists linguists have been
trying to develop a map how can we
display or portray this bio cultural
diversity we showed languages in terms
of hotspots biological hotspots but what
about this bio cultural thing combining
the two it's very difficult because
they're two very different types of data
and information so combining the two
interpret a single index is almost not
impossible it's very difficult and so
this was a very crude attempt by David
Lowe and John Harmon and entire
countries are coated a single color here
and here an entire continent certain
color so the deeper the color the more
endangered are both of biological
elements on the cultural elements within
that region and it doesn't show that for
because of the lack of fine grain so
these areas up here or up here in the
northwest weather or even across
northern Australia where they're huge
numbers of very small indigenous groups
remaining this was another attempt that
UNESCO did with along with the World
Wildlife Fund is just as unsatisfying
the colors here are just picking the bio
regions of the world and you can't see
at this scale but they're just little
dots everywhere it just shows where an
endangered culture or danger languages
so they're just superimpose one thing
over another so it's still a work in
progress
so I show this this is a rare plant in
Hawaii and extinct in the wild this is
cyanea trunk eater the only place in the
world you can see this is in a test tube
at the Lyon Arboretum what we can do is
we can clone it every individual will be
genetically identical at least we can
clone it and if there's a habitat
suitable we can put it back out into
nature once we grow these things up in
the greenhouse but you can't put a
culture in a test-tube you can do that
with plants but once the culture has
gone is gone and no lesser person there
Francois Chekov Nobel laureate in
medicine in 1965 said that in humans
natural diversity is further
strengthened by cultural diversity and
I'm hoping that we can as we develop our
programs more at the Cornell plantations
and with partnership from people at
Cornell other departments that we can
dive into this issue more deeply there
are a number of international entities
treaties and conventions and such the
rule draw these two issues together the
Convention on Biological Diversity which
every nation in the world has ratified
except the u.s. George Herbert Walker
Bush signed it but Congress didn't
ratify it so where we tried to live up
to its tenets to his articles but
there's no mandate that we do so but I
think it seems to be the right thing to
do and most people who are working
gardens and museums respect the
Convention on Biological Diversity but
in a number of places within this
convention including this article HJ
they do refer to maintaining indigenous
and local communities for the
conservation and sustainable use of
biological diversity so they're making
an attempt here again to bring these two
together we can't do the one without the
other something that's a little bit more
close to home for those in the botanic
garden world is the global strategy for
plant conservation which came out of the
Convention on Biological Diversity and
the number of us from gardens around the
world worked quite a bit on developing
this over the last ten years or so and
that has targets we had targets from
2000-2010 and now we have new targets
from 2010 to 2020
such as
in Victoria and having electronical
databases that document every living
plant in the world and all these kinds
of things because how are we going to
preserve what we have and must be know
exactly what we have another full extent
of it
now what are these targets again like
the convention of Biological Diversity
again refers to this intersection
between biological and cultural
conservation halting the decline of
plant resources and associated
indigenous and local knowledge
innovations and practices I'm that's
just a snippet out of that target so you
can get the gist of it and there I think
there are 18 or 20 of these targets some
of them have to do as I said with
digitizing the floor of the world and
these kinds of things where you can say
yes we've done this much we've done
we've done 75% of it or 85 or whatever
the case may be developing new
educational programs or communication
strategies around all of this this is a
much harder one to get a grip on and is
the one that tends to be ignored just
because it's a little bit more difficult
to address
but Gardens are addressing this
nonetheless those of you who've been to
New York much or been to Queens Botanic
Garden know that it's probably and one
of the most ethnically diverse places in
the u.s. and they've made an explicit
attempt to draw in the various ethnic
groups that are within their their area
and give them a place where they can
express themselves culturally
particularly as it relates to foods and
pants and that within their daily lives
and so they have a number of events a
number of festivals that aren't catered
just for you know for Filipinos to
Filipinos but Filipinos to everybody
else so everybody can get a taste
figuratively and literally of what that
culture represents and how plants are
central centrally important to the
maintenance of their culture I've been
working on and off with Johannes Bosma
Probab in the alley in in Jordan who is
establishing a network of new botanic
gardens throughout Jordan there'll be a
main central garden in Amman and another
satellite gardens throughout the country
and those satellite ones are intended to
do thing two things one is to showcase
the biota
and the biological diversity of that
particular region and the others that
show the the cultural significance of
the peoples in that region because they
vary from place to place so these are
even though she's not calling it that
these are biocultural Gardens and she's
financing these personally because the
government is not doing it even though
she's part of the royal family so she's
doing it herself and another place
that's doing this and and I consulted
with them briefly a couple of years ago
was in South Korea for they're building
a new city south west of Seoul the city
is gonna be huge it's going to be about
three times the size of Paris or some
such thing and it's enormous and this is
a scale model of they have in the
Visitor Center showcasing this new big
R&D and city and have all these fancy
apartments all these kinds of things the
only thing they've done so far is build
a seawall which is the world's longest
seawall 35 kilometers long with a
four-lane highway on the top and two
two-lane highways on either side that's
really grotesque in some ways so they're
doing this in this estuary and the only
saving grace and the lighting in here
hasn't allowed to show up very clearly
is right in here this is what they
wanted me to come there for is they're
building a 100 hectare biocultural
garden so it's gonna be a garden that
showcases the biological heritage and
cultural heritage of that part of the
Korean Peninsula and the Chinese
mainland is just across the sea from
there which I thought was quite an
interesting I'm not particularly a fan
of the rest of what they're proposing to
do here particularly always big golf
courses and that kind of thing but this
is just a plan of these things change
and as you know given the current
economic state of the world is probably
just as likely this will never happen
but there are people who are thinking
about this at least in terms of how can
we bring people and the cultural
heritage of the world more close to the
issues that we're facing and with
respect to conserving the natural world
so as Don alluded to when I was at
University of Hawaii I established a
center for bio cultural studies there
and what we did was draw in people from
anthropology linked
sticks the law school as they had law of
faculty who are looking at climate
change and it's impacts on indigenous
peoples and resource extraction
indigenous intellectual property rights
and all these kinds of things it ran the
gamut I mean there wasn't probably was
very few departments at the University
it didn't in some way have some
connection to this particular issue and
we developed partnerships as part of
that an mo use with the University of
Auckland and New Zealand but we were
doing in Hawaii relates to what they go
down there with a Maori population
UNESCO was interested in this too at the
University of South Pacific and Fiji the
Smithsonian through their recovering
voices program the east-west Center
which is a non-profit big think-tank in
Honolulu looking at ways in which
Western and Eastern cultures can
intersect and support one another so
there's a lot of interest and this is
just a matter of articulating what the
issues are and making connections with
people in other disciplines we held a
which is now every other year an
international conference on endangered
languages at the University of Hawaii
and we had people come there from all
over the world including people from
Google they sent six people to this we
had no idea the companies came and they
said announce themselves and after the
conference they said we want to help you
build a website just for endangered
languages so they did they built it for
us and now all we have to do all is find
the linguist after a botanist
ethnomusicologists and others who are
documenting endangered languages and
cultures and put their information on
this public publicly accessible site
it's like a well managed or well edited
wiki it really is what it is so they're
people now the University of Hawaii who
managed managed this and those new
information comes and they vetted and
make sure it's all up to snuff
and how bringing all this back closer to
home you saying what the hell does this
have to do with or now oh but and this
is the whitewash it shouldn't have said
this is white pine tree who knows what
this tree is come on Robert so this is
an iconic tree in the northern no sort
of mixed hardwoods forests everywhere
from Minnesota to the to the Northeast
and it holds a special place in Native
American culture the Haudenosaunee I
said that right Confederacy the original
MOOCs MOOC as Mohawk Oneida Onondaga
Cayuga and Seneca that's how I remember
just remember MOOCs for those are your
in higher education so so try to know
what that is so they so to them the
white pine is is a very key element of
their cultural history and we had a
display on this at the never knock on
Center when I first came and I still
don't know it was just by happenstance
that I'm interested in this and happened
to be there or somebody said let's get
this guy done anyway so they have
there's all the symbolism so they have
how many needles in the festival
professor of a white pine five okay so
of the [ __ ] the they represent each of
those Native American Confederate uh
nations that are part of this
Confederacy and this on symbolism does
of Eagle on the top of the tree and all
this kind of thing but of the tree falls
over if it's a tipped over in a
windstorm or whatever the root ball
comes up you got this big depression in
the ground and that's where they would
bury their weapons and then cover them
up and then the rainwater of the stream
or whatever would carry away that
violence and I'd be the end of war
supposedly anyway so they call it here
the tree of the great long leaves but
it's also referred to in their culture
as the tree of peace so if the white
pine were to disappear not that a will
but it is being threatened has been
threatened over the centuries by logging
over logging and one disease or another
and you know this it's possible that
something like this could disappear from
a culture and there it goes another
piece of that cultures integrity
so some other things we're doing a done
where a cow can speak to these much more
expertly than can i but we can also
refer to and acknowledge and respect
other cultures just through horticulture
as well and so we plan on continuing to
promote this East Asian garden that Don
was involved in developing as a way to
get people more engaged in Asian
cultures and how plants have been used
in those cultures for ornamental
aesthetic and other purposes so there'll
be some focus unless things change
dramatically on Korean some aspects of
Korean Japanese in Korean culture and
how they use plants in various in
various ways
and this is not just a if you think
about nineteen percent I read of Cornell
undergraduates self-identify as Asian so
that's either Asian American or from
Asia coming here from Asia for school
that's a significant population here and
it's very little here that's for them
and we don't have to do something just
for them but it's also an opportunity
for us to learn more about them so it
goes both ways then the peony and
perennial garden which may be in that
great alone area or a portion of it we
depending on how the fundraising goes
and all this kind of thing things always
change and scales change but peonies are
another plant that are very important
some aspects of Asian horticulture and
gardens so the ways in which we can draw
different cultures in here and then from
there we can explore out in any number
of different avenues so if your honor
what the hell did was that all about
here's the summary slide we're living
museums so we have to maintain our
horticulture and educational excellence
that goes without saying so some people
say well you good well you're not gonna
be a botanic garden anymore yes we are
we're gonna be a better one and a more
impactful one and we have to remain
indispensable to to Cornell to the
Faculty of the students add to the
community and forge relationships and
partnerships with people in other
disciplines and the humanities in
particular and social sciences and and
do more in terms of informing people
about this intimate link and this sort
of Cove
evolutionary link between nature's and
cultures now you should like to close
things by this phrase from Shakespeare
that he'd put in the words of Ulysses
and I think otherwise I just can't get
through tortoise and Cressida
but anyway said one touch of nature
makes the whole world kin and I think if
we use this as our mantra moving forward
and think about some this nature and
culture thing who will have left the
world a better place
thank you very much for you take horses
and so there's I have five practice
students come to your time to practice I
welcome you with the best career advice
I said don't focus yes hope embedded in
this discourse about biochemistry things
are related to getting together
it's really useful they don't make
course paths one saying ones that are
hard copy I'll take them back to the day
you know something on the table
musicology us what up the case we need
so I think it can make your head
whatever you wanted to be great loving
person - this is an apology or not
one of us Ben yes
plantations more active more
two departments
well there are doing some of that extra
stickers that have with the Paul and
Sonia review you have a pretty good
relationship how English department I
want to expand on that theater
there is a 2008 responsibility
I'll say for that mr. project he's been
gone throughout the world videotaping
cultures they disappear in clusters and
pumpkin that need to do them up their
relationship for the nice round thing so
I'm interested in working with people
like that as well we can work with them
directly here embracing these people
into
it's funny doesn't know us but thinking
about it which we can get some of this
information out to these lecture series
and so what if we had this woman who's
Indian who did this to multimedia kind
of thing called Himalayan snow where
she's looking at climate change
Molly's snow melting glaciers melting
and the impact that's having those
cultures a little bit of American
mountains there and then what in fact
that cultural loss was having a
Republican Tea Party because now her
culture there is disappearing is
associated with this loss herself so you
can connect those dots generation
generationally and connect them to
effectively especially in country and so
what she does is she has this video
thing minutes playing while she's
talking over it as well and is extremely
powerful so I don't want it to keep the
tactic necessarily or lecturing as we
get more into these things
we need to not only of course their each
man is good to some extent we also need
to take that magnificent portion in some
ways to overdue
yes yeah change okay I was really
pleased to see when you were talking
about a cultural diversity that then you
brought the issue back to you know kind
of where we are today with the footage
something and an Iroquois I think one of
the issues that I mean it sounds easy to
talk about preserving plants and
everybody wants to protect its a white
pine or the black ash or those types of
things and thinking about you know
forming partnerships with with native
peoples in in the region but the place
where that gets hard is in terms of
political sovereignty and this last year
2014 was the 400th year of the tumor
wampum which represents the the
political agreement between Iroquois
partitioning peoples and non native
peoples that started with the Dutch but
then it also kind of frames the
relationship between the hood nashoni
and us people today and where that comes
the kind of rubber meets the road in
difficulty is that much of New York
state is under land claim conflict
meaning that these people for whom we
would like to save the white pine have
serious and legitimate claims to
property in New York state based on
political sovereignty and so to not
recognize that is to kind of frame the
question in not a trivial way but in a
way that doesn't really
nice the native indigenous peoples in
New York State in northern North America
our indigenous political entities with
the desire to have their own land their
own government and all the rest and so
bio cultural conservation when we form
partnerships like that to be effective
the very first thing has to recognize
the political sovereignty of those
groups so I salute you for bringing up
the by national diversity and say let's
not forget that there is political and
all sorts of issues that go along with
us right here in our own backyard and
talk to people in your County about come
friendly they are with the human Nations
and you'll probably get slapped in the
face right because they don't like the
Cubism and they could care less about
the way that's true when I was sitting
up this undergoing that ok something my
I did get was the related emeritus fall
in love Native American I mean Native
Hawaiians it aligns all the faculty
there were all engaged
my studies program as well as in the law
school another so yes we did bring in
all that political thing and it's a
pretty dynamic system there - it isn't
quiet and ok Ottoman army and but
through these different partnerships you
develop respect from there you can
afford again
there's also these things I was working
out quite well and white right now and I
had always working out about that at
home
situation here will be resolved in some
way
everybody's unhappy
this is where it seems that in
considering this rapid loss of
indigenous languages that it's either
being caused by Geographic changes such
as these people are living on the atolls
no longer being able to live there
because of rising ocean levels or
because members of the group speak those
languages or migrating cities and no
longer identifying that their culture
where the people are just dying out so
given those factors what realistically
practically can be done and preserved in
smelting like mussels look that all just
business more than anybody else must
love us for that and generally what
happens is that go to these places
purposes like grain
your digital
some of them say we won't turn off
we haven't read I am large you need
better off if you disobey them you have
a post anyway so these languages in
public don't die out because that's what
they want
there are many others that he wants
ultimately our cognitive alternative
packaging disappears as this the least
we could do we are kind of austerity and
understandeth
have been perfect so we know where all
these words might get and stories and
songs and acids me
getting it Richard from that beyond that
was having some places
I was training programs maybe older
people bringing people who can help with
that
developing question parts also felt
that's working with traditional
medicinal sport and Sony's office
haven't acetate
language of these past our abilities for
you can use those as teaching tools
I'm not an expert in that there are any
number of different ways that I can be
diversity but a big thing in order for
language a viable is that it has the
more than SP cast down from generation
to the next and so we're looking to see
if a language is a big best iversity you
look at whose language being transferred
transmitted
of course and what I've noticed
consumers and incredible interest in
plants and medicine and health and it's
rare that you go to Gardens England so
they're very really very conscious of
this I mean the public is constantly
consuming all kinds of dental stuff I
wish their food us what they think
so I took my question how it gardens get
into a topic which deals with medicine
deals with health which everybody's
interested and you can touch especially
in the ancient medicine of the American
Indians from North America South America
this incredible weather sense and I'm
just
well we in networks are Donets
implications we have 17 themed beds we
have two beds are devoted to medicinal
plants many of which are originated in
requesters in Europe European culture
and a few from China and a few from
India and we also have one of the
offensive herbs of the name of of
American Indians it's very small and
there are located all around us in the
treaties the trees our medicine the
shrubs our medicine work you know they
they have medicinal properties so their
feature of all around us not just within
this confines in this very small bed and
the Wildflower apartments of plantations
as the woodland they plant some of which
are medicinal and some are edible so
it's through interpretive programs I
think that we learn a lot more because
we can only feature a small very small
percentage within the context of the
earth part
so then bring in guest speakers native
guest speakers
have gene give us some programs and
maybe network help us network with the
indigenous population there's a State
Historic Park upananda gun which is in
Victor New York outside picture New York
about an hour to half north of here and
they are State Park on the site of an
old Seneca historic village where they
had 150 long houses and it's a
magnificent sight there great resource
for it but also anything collection said
in the gardens available to say that
researchers and students
so they can
to use the plant materials and stop the
cannibals
test them to see that you would have a
potentially new technically yes so we
could be a resource for that actually we
need to cut things off the one who
gambled a doctor or that production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu